tout le monde sait que la ville du
marais à certaines difficultés
financières maintenant les premières
priorités
ça sera bien sûr de renouer des liens
avec le personnel de la municipalité
nous savons qu'il ya eu des grèves nous
savons qu'il ya eu des tensions et
encore dernièrement nous savons aussi
que le service technique a été déménagé
et aujourd'hui dispersés dans la ville
donc nous estimons que les conditions ne
sont pas requises donc dans un premier
temps nous nous attacherons à faire en
sorte que le personnel retrouve une
certaine sérénité de meilleurs liens
avec son utilité bien sûr tout ce qu'il
dit ce qu'elle fera en tout cas une
cette nouvelle municipalité
ça sera surtout de faire en sorte que la
tante de la population soins satisfaite
avec un personnel qui travaille dans de
bonnes conditions
on arrive à de meilleurs résultats